I I've been following I have been  following what the oh no gentleman has  been saying he sent some very good  dispatches from the front in terms of  knocking on doors in rochdale and this  is what he says any labour politician  that says to you they knock on a door an  Ed Miliband is popular they're telling  lies about his own side he says you know  this North London elite view of the  world just doesn't play in rochdale  Rotherham runcorn or anywhere else  beginning with an hour outside the m25  I'd like to encourage him to do more  interviews because he could add reading  redditch redruth reigate Rosie  rossendale  what we are and probably Ross sides to  the way they're going  thank you very much mr. speaker here I  don't think so not